My name is Hamna. I am a commercial
freelance talent and I'm trying to
become actor. I have a question.
>> Trying to become
>> You mentioned that a woman's beauty
show.
>> You are trying to become
>> sis. You're taking too long.
>> I'm trying to become an actor.
>> Actor?
>> Yes.
>> Actress? Not actor. Actress.
>> Yeah. Yes. Yes.
>> Actress.
>> I have a question. You mentioned that a
woman's beauty should only be shown to
her husband and children. Why is female
obedience often associated with
concealment? What about women whose
talent are in public speaking or being
on camera? Does that make their
obedience less valid? In Islam is public
visibility only limited.
>> Finish. Your time is gone. You're asking
such a long question.
>> Okay. Okay.
>> Okay. Anyway, she wants to become an
actress.
>> Yes.
>> Actor means she'll have to change your
sex first.
>> Okay.
>> You want to sister? Your question is
over.
>> If you speak more, we'll have to end the
session. I understood your question.
>> You want to become an actress.
>> Yes.
>> In Islam, a woman cannot become actress.
It is haram. In acting, you have to show
your body, show your face. This is going
against the hijab.
>> You're wearing a nakab and you want to
act. Can you act while wearing a nakab?
No. So, it's contradicting. So, if you
want to become actress, it is against
the teachings of Islam. A woman cannot
do modeling. A woman cannot do acting.
You're wearing a nakab and you want to
do acting. Can you do acting with nakab?
>> Yes.
>> You'll have to remove your nakab.
Correct.
>> Yes.
>> You have to remove your hijab. So hijab
is not only of the clothes. Hijab is the
way you walk, the way you talk. So
modeling, acting, public thinking, all
these are against the teaching of Islam
for a woman. So I so may Allah give you
haya. Change your profession, become a
Muslim da that will help you more.